you don't have to like what I did Rick I
don't they just accept it
hey youtubers it's Charlie this week The
Walking Dead was all about letting go of
things or trying to let go of things
Rick literally let go of Carol he shown
let go of her search for the governor
Tyreese kind of let go of his anger and
Ben was unable to let go of a few things
overall the episode was a bit of a pause
on the fleu storyline so it was kind of
a breath of fresh air so we did get to
relax just a little bit and deal with
some of the things that have been
happening over this season so first
let's talk about the most important bits
and then I'll do my review biggest thing
first
Rick totally banished Carol from the
group I don't think he did it so much
because he hates what she did
she kind of spends the entire episode
trying to convince him that what she did
was necessary you don't have to like it
just accept it
Levine if he has accepted it I think he
feels that the group won't be able to
accept it particularly Tyreese he would
definitely murder her the minute he
found out that Carol killed Karen even
though their final goodbye was really
bittersweet I felt like it actually left
on a very hopeful note we kind of get
this acknowledgment of Carol's character
becoming this stone-cold survivor I mean
she really started out as this housewife
who really had trouble living with the
decisions she made and now she's at a
point where she's the one that's making
the decisions that need to be made and
Rick is actually having trouble with
that so don't worry I'm pretty sure we
will be seeing Carol again this season
like I said Rick is definitely having
trouble being a leader again
I like Carol's quote I think it was one
of the best in the episode when she said
you can be a farmer Rick you can't just
be a farmer overall the episode was
actually booked ended by this really
amazing speech from Lizzie at the
beginning and this song at the end
everything changes it's all about these
characters kind of learning to accept
things and Rick is really just kind of
still learning to do that I feel like
even though the people that Rick and
Carol ran into were funny in a crazy way
the real humor in the episode was all in
Daryl's group and it was mostly Michonne
and Daryl that lipstick joke was great
normally Michonne is so full of rage
you'd never see her make a joke like
that but she had this really nice arc in
this episode where she got to this
really Zen place and obviously she's
really trying to help Daryl out but I
love that she's gonna let go of her
search for the governor just because
she's really looking for justice and not
so much revenge anymore more to that
than our Tyreese actually had this
similar journey in this episode where by
the end he had become the voice of
reason whereas at the beginning he was
still kind of like in that Tyrese animal
mode it's really hard to know where his
character
is going but I think he's still kind of
learning to accept the fact that Karen
is dead and obviously the minute he
finds out that Carol did it he's
probably gonna try and go find her but I
did think it was great that we finally
got some answers about the bank
character so I think a lot of people
thought that he might be secretly
working for the governor like an
infiltrator just because he seemed
really off but we really just found out
that he's just an alcoholic he just has
this crushing crushing problem so
obviously that is probably going to get
him into some big trouble with the
walkers later I mean literally he almost
gets pulled over the edge trying to
rescue his bottle of liquor let me know
if you thought that Daryl was actually
gonna push him over the side after that
I actually kind of thought he was gonna
push him off that roof into the pile of
walkers and how great is it though that
Tyreese was the voice of reason in that
moment but the real purpose of the
episode was finding all this medicine to
bring back to Hershel obviously we don't
know how that's gonna turn out but the
teaser for the next episode kind of
implies that the flu storyline will be
over after next episode so the people
that are gonna die will die and the
people that are gonna live are gonna
live so we'll find out who's left at the
end of that episode be sure to subscribe
to get my video for that I'll be posting
that right after the episode airs you
shouldn't let me know in the comments
what were your favorite moments and did
you agree with Rick's decision to banish
Carol did he do the right thing honestly
like I said I think that he's not doing
it because he hates her I think he
understands why she did what she did I
think he just feels like the group won't
be able to accept that it'll just cause
too much chaos in the prison
in other news I've got a very special
Doctor Who 50th anniversary video coming
tomorrow morning I've got some news
about the next trailer that's coming as
well as some special news about content
that I'll be making with the BBC and
Nerdist so be sure to check back
tomorrow morning for that and don't
forget Sleepy Hollow and agents of
shield her back this week so we're kind
of back to a normal TV schedule so I'll
have my regular 8 videos this week as
always if you really want to help me up
please like and share this video using
the tools below and you can click here
to learn all about the Walking Dead this
season and you can click here to get
that special Doctor Who videos since I
posted thanks so much for watching
high five see you guys tomorrow
you